hi there steve coffin here today i want
to talk about japanese particles
um
i see from
exchanges on the internet and elsewhere
that
japanese particles seem to cause
problems for some people who are
studying japanese
at any rate at any rate it is identified
as a feature of japanese
that is i guess unique
um
when i studied japanese and i did it
largely on my own
living in japan
i was unaware of the term japanese
particles didn't know that this was an
issue
i just
read a lot
originally just in hiragana we had this
naganuma series which were these endless
stories including
momotaro and whatever you know stories
he could drum up all in hiragana
which was tough going
and so i read those
and i'll show you later some of the
other material that i used
and it became
evident to me that in japan in japanese
a number of things were happening that
were different from english word order
for example the verb comes at the end
even if they don't tell you that fairly
quickly you start to realize that
um
and that there were these little markers
so verb comes at the end
and to be perfectly honest there's a
distinction between wa and ga they have
essentially the same
function
and i think they're largely
interchangeable there's undoubtedly some
explanation of how they differ
eventually you simply get used to using
them in
context the y is a sort of more definite
affirmation
of say watashi
it seems to be softer i can't tell you
more than that no one has ever corrected
me on it so that's it so far is the one
that god is concerned
now if i'm giving a book to someone
hon which is book hong o because the
direct object takes the
o
and ana
ni
and so forth so
there are a number of these little words
and they're not only those little words
that come
after the
say the noun
so
which is a table
table no no is like apostrophe
apostrophe s indicates possession one of
its uses
uh table no ueni no ueni
on top of the table so that
a lot of these little words kind of
replace the prepositions in english call
them particles call them whatever you
want
again
uh
if you want to google for japanese
particles there is an endless number of
pages that will explain the complete
list and what they stand for
but none of that is going to enable a
learner
to master these
aspects of the japanese language
unless
you know nothing's going to help you
unless you actually expose yourself to a
lot of the language through listening
and reading so i just wanted to mention
that when i started with japanese i read
the naganuma all in hiragana for it must
have been eight months or so just read
read read read read read there was no
audio in those days
and then i can't remember what else i
did but
in every language i have learned there
are certain
items of content that i have
loved and that have
influenced my learning of the language
in the case of japanese of course i had
the advantage that i could read chinese
characters
and at some point amongst the various
bits of content that i found in japanese
bookstores was this thing
okay now i would have bought this in the
early 70s
it is a history of the showa era
so it has all kinds of pictures
and text here
and
came with
nhk's
the actual soundtrack
of
announcers nhk that's the japanese
national broadcasting system
they're
you know news stories of the day and so
you follow the history of the showa era
i listened to these i understood 20 30
40 50 percent i listened to it over and
over again it was a wonderful
place to learn japanese
so in all of this i never knew there was
such a term as japanese particles i just
exposed myself to the language and the
brain has this capacity to get used to
what's happening and to sort it out okay
now i think it's an advantage in the
beginning
to identify
this is a verb this is an adjective this
is a noun so because otherwise it's just
noise
and we are moving right now we have our
programmers at link are are setting up a
system so that the part of speech will
be identified if you save a word okay
this is an adjective that helps a lot
but after a while that just gets blended
into
this gradual absorption absorption of
the language
and and an increasing familiarity with
how the language works
and eventually you don't need to worry
about
particles and if you do have
a moment of uncertainty about which
particle to use you can google and you
can find umpteen explanations so
sure if you're interested in looking up
japanese particles you can find lots
better explanations than i gave you just
now however fundamentally to become
comfortable in using japanese particles
or the subjunctive in spanish or
you know prepositions and or pronouns in
italian you just have to expose yourself
to a lot of the language there is no
shortcut in my view so there you have it
i may not be tremendously helpful but i
would encourage learners of japanese not
to focus too much
on the bits and pieces but to make sure
they expose themselves to as much
interesting compelling content as
possible thank you for listening bye for
now
[Music]
you